hello and welcome to co play gifts for
lark I'm chopped by cat okay the good
german i am so how does he take many
takes him it takes so what to do it slow
p should be six bit of a bit of an
unconventional on move but that is some
actually quite okay for black let's see
what he's doing he wants to he goes for
the direct refutation let's say yeah
this is looking very logical and it
looks strange that black boots this or
SS pawn on d6 but this is not in fact
such a big deal as it turns out the
thing that I don't remember is how
exactly I should play the pollution
bishop here ya go to c5 as well Jim
Knight f6 off not sure ya do a castle
short or do a castle long yeah I'll go
short but i'm not sure the poorness is
really looking like a like a weakness
but not clear how is going to really do
much with it not sure but it's not spend
too much time he just takes it ok yeah
it's not a very attractive position i
have to admit i mean i don't think i
have any problems but it's not exactly
looking like i'm going to win this game
quickly or any way at all so what's
going on here not much really not much i
would have considered to take with
opponents in this position with white
version it's not a it's not very
important no yeah this is just extremely
dry yeah okay if y place in this in this
way as he played it's extremely
difficult for black to to do anything as
we as we see em it's just extremely
equal
Tim not sure if I wanted to now a five
by white get rather want to prevent that
maybe we still get something happening
in this ending 35 here maybe
yeah I have no porn porn leavin so I
cannot do much yeah or anything at all
okay see 6b five I can do but this is
not really okay I mean I can do that
it's not it's not bad maybe five rupee
seven min so he's doing absolutely
nothing I don't think I can do much
though it really not okay so what's
going on here there before yes moves
like books if I had that that really
doesn't do anything at all you have a
take I'm rather be cleaning my own
position like I just have to stay put
this one or am I actually whistling my
position here if you take sigh but I get
the edge file but I don't think I don't
think you will you will probably play h5
mmm yeah okay what I wonder is if
something like see voice is an idea what
am i killing myself and ce4 takes before
this kind of thing King d3 shaking
probably not really making any progress
what I can try us maybe this intensive
for his ruckus is not that great I have
a deathless really try to try to do
something interesting here where there's
nothing interesting to do
it's going for the eighth a pawn or what
is he doing I have G for he cannot
easily do something on the queenside I
have G for coming let's try ok I should
have thought I'm morning a little bit
more of it mmm let's chat shake i feel i
feel that this is shaking it feels shaky
check
I should have just played passively and
make a draw probably this sir can get
ugly 40-something seconds and it is
somewhat complicated
if you take this I take h 5 which is
more interesting to take
so I will push this pawn and have Kings
you for coming up make'em maybe take age
6 now 25 seconds that wasn't that was
bad what I did it's probably still a
draw but wasn't particularly well played
and that is a draw who's the king i'm
checking check game drawn and this is a
kind of thing a complete ass would
continue yeah i was four against three
just with luke i came so it's it's joy
at the end it was very difficult to do
something i tried a little bit gaining
some space but it's probably just to
draw yeah the structure is actually not
nothing much for y de Paul looks a
little bit of but it is just um yeah
just too little really to do too much
with the only thing is I can do
absolutely nothing so that line is
probably check not particularly well
suited to do something I could have
taken between hours just like you let's
play this ending and oh wow that's a
nice one check
and did not see that yeah this is I
think very dry and white has the better
structured it's not much going on I try
to gain some space here at least but you
cannot really do all that much Jim now
there is no no active way forward in
some way here I felt like I had problems
check that is really possible walking
your hair here i'm having problems chest
trying to play as actively as possible
with this and somehow it worked out but
i don't feel it should have worked out
okay five that don't really think that
this is amounting to much at the end
probably more than what happened in the
game yeah this is just just equal I
don't think there's any big ham point so
computer want to take a five here check
so I grab this and go here this is
supposed to be better for wild
why srei dude don't understand the
evaluation at all how can Y do not now k
no it no it goes down yxy exactly oh
look a five okay not a fun but how can
you I'd be better than this position
that somewhere somehow difficult to
believe like even if I do this ok six
like look here kinking what King c3i
attacked this is just a draw maybe not
if he gets h6 it's not easy at all ok so
what happens if i take this 15 you
should draw with the a booth eh pawn no
okay yeah probably probably game where
draw was the favorite all along ok guys
thanks for watching